Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Hand simulator, so I might be playing some hand simulator
Because I hate myself shift changes out
which hand you lower with the mouse you grab you can just grab with everything...you can
there we go
I think the problem is the tendency for this bullshit to come back for some reason I have to- I have to like
Express
Like constant force in a certain direction for it to be able to move. Ah whatever it doesn't matter alright
I did nothing- two-
Oh! There we go okay hang on
alright, okay
*sigh* At least I don't have to unload the individual bullets for this bad boy. Let me get this bad boy right here
heh heh- How do I rotate...? there we go
Rotate hand- rotatae and three two one contact got it hey, I've even got- nope that's not gonna work, okay
Apparently I didn't have contact all right, here we go. alright and grip
No, no, let's nudge... nudge... nudge...
Nudge... nudge. no why are you not nudging?
Why why no- there we go nudge okay, and then grab and then lift?
Slam that bad boy home!
Why are you lifting like that that doesn't make any sense for a- it's not that heavy
It's not gonna drag your goddamn hand out alright hang on
And also why do I have a proclivity to play these rage games?
You know I don't fucking know like I said I hate myself
I think that's the only answer here. get shove in you okay hang on we're gonna switchy-swatchy. We're gonna hold you in place
We're gonna hold you. switchy-swatchy. shove shove and hold. Oh, This is erotic gret. Okay, you're gonna
Let go you're gonna really really slam that bad boy. Okay, just pat it like an old friend grab tight shift
switch
No, why did you let go??
*annoyed sound* Just grab and shove. Why?!
What are you doing? What kind of- what point are you trying to make? alright
You shove right there stay right there
You grab, you shove shove slam it home. Sl-
Okay, what if I pick up the gun in this hand why is the pinkie?
Slam down like that let go of your goddamn pinky okay
What if I pick up the gun if I pick up the gun then I I wouldn't have a cho-
Woah, all right then. Oh rotateh, rotat okay shift. All right. We're gonna slam this bad boy home
Just like I know how to spank an ass. ;) I'm gonna slam you back WHAP!
easy peasy
*laughs*
If there's one thing Markiplier knows how to do it's how to slap an ass
I'm gonna, I'm gonna shoot the bangy- bangy
*laughing* I still have to cock the gun after I get done with all this bull shit
I'm just trying to position it where my hand could actually grab it.
again, this is one of those skills that I just didn't want-
ouh That's not right.
that's not right..
hmm.
This is a fundamental problem of picking things up when they're flat on the ground when your hand behaves like a like an epileptic
Badger- OH!
Apparently I didn't need to cock it.
and why is my hand drifting? my hand is here.
I'm not controlling this. It's just drifting. Why?
okay fine, then I guess
I guess we've got this. alright, rotateh, rotateh, rotateh.
bring the aim up, k
No, why am- why am I leaning forward? Why would I be leaning forward?
That makes no sense
am i trying to aim down the sights
Come on bring it up. No, rotateh, rotateh and then bring your wrist-
ahh, nooo
ahh, ohh
That's fun. That's fun, you can draw a figure eight. ooookay. We're gonna go- we're gonna go uhh
It's a kill shot, hang on
let's do a trick shot here
nope
Nope, okay, I guess we're not gonna shooty-shooty-bang-bang anymore
We were in shooty-shooty-bang-bang position, and now we're suddenly not.
okay. alright. That's stupid. you're stupid
I'm dropping you. hopp. good thing-
ooooo
*laughing*
ah, That, that seems perfect
Now watch me fuck this up because it's not perfect obviously and and it's gonna go very wrong for me, okay
Yeah, I think we're on target the shadows are aligned the stars and the planets
woahh
okay hang on
okay.. lower, lower, GRIP
HEHhehHEheHEH
Now that is a good grip! now that's how you properly hold a gun right there
*laughing* hang on..
Can I... AH I can shoot!
YES
okay, aim, aim, aim
shoot. *bang*
Hah! so close to a headshot!
*bang*
OH! Headshot headshot, baby. Headshot! Why did I get zero points for that?
Oh my god. I don't care. I got a headshot
Do you guys s- *bang* oh my god. I was close not quite ..
ah Come on. I'm right by the head. I'm right by the head
*bang* Ah come on
*bang* oh Jeez, I'm the worst.
*bang* Oh god
*bang*
oh jeez okay, I've got to be out of bullets by now..
oh my- yup, im out of bullets
goddamnit, i've got ONE headshot
I've got so many bullets by the heads. Let me see if I can bring this goddamn thing forward
I can't believe I'm getting better at this game. I don't like the fact that I'm getting better at this game
I should not be getting better at this game this game is not
Not what I should be doing
Are you here? oh gods like a horror it is scary *laughs*
That's scary. Are you here yet?
Oh that's as close as you're gonna get. Why is it in shadow? why are you shadowed? maybe I got to put it back
Just a bit, but you guys are gonna see how close I was to success. No please just grab it
eh. Grab and- no. Don't flip me off you fucko. Alright just go back a bit. Are you still in shadow? no!
Where's the bullet holes you fuck you fuck you fuck
Take some of that. It won't let me spawn the other gun
It will only let me get this one!
Is it cause I have no score? Hang on let me see if I can do this quickly
Grab- grab it. Gr- gently grasp it okay and rotateh
Rot-
Rotateh, maybe I can- uh I think I can score points
I must have just been on the outskirt of the head
And it didn't give me any points cuz I think it costs points to get other guns. Oh come on slam it in there ah
Slam that hot dog home come on just slam- Oh, you're right in the hole. Get in the hole!
Okay, if- if you're n- the guns being- guns being all shy about- oh no *sigh*
If if I can't bring the clip to the gun you better believe I'm gonna bring the gun to the clip alright here we
Go slam home-a Slammy Slammy the Celebi come on salami. Celebi?
Please it's right there. Rotateh
Ro- *tongue sound*
ha
Come on. It's oh my god. They both. Don't want to be near each other and I can't blame them
they just don't want to kill
I understand but this poor target needs to be shot. No God Frick a dick
Now it's the wrong way now. It's the wrong fucking way. Now it's the wrong fucking way, okay alright
I can deal with this if I can just pick it up if I can pick it up. That'd be great no
*Frusturated ahhhs*
Okay, let's try that again
Grab. No. Grab. Why? What? Grab. Yes? okay
I guess I'll take it you know what I don't have much else to go by but I guess I'll take it
Oh, my god, please just go in the hole. Please just oh my god there it was in the hole hang on
Why is this so hard now? Why is this suddenly
everything's fighting me. it wasn't doing this before!
Okay
my shift
NoooOoo
mMmm
right there shift
n- ugh fuck
It used to be that it would hold it in between each one why am I-
I just don't understand why the camera decides to move sometimes like why would the camera move there? Why is the camera moving?
I don't have any control over the fucking camera
come on come on. You're- you're right. You're right- ugh
Oh my god. Oh my god. Ah frick a dick okay, alright. Let's just set that back down
What if I do it like this? What if I just try to stand it up like?
No like no like no okay. That's not gonna work cuz my wrist will not BEND as far as it needs to go
Okay, stand it up nope
*sigh*
UGGGHH
Up no no no no no
Here yes, no. No. Yes. Oh, oh my god. Oh
Oh
What is this? I'm not moving my hand
I'm not moving! Hey what, why?
Not moving not fucking moving it's moving. I'm not moving
Let go of that
Let's escape nope we're out. We're out. Okay. We're out. We're gonna try horror. I don't know what horror is but I hope whoa
Hi
Okay, you're coming closer. I don't like that
uh wait um
Wait hang on
Whoa hey, whoa there ease ease up on it hang on whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa?
Hey, whoa whoa whoa?
Woah, HEY
*creepy lady screams crazily*
*Mark snickers*
What are you supposed to do? what?? *laugh*
What are you supposed to do? Wait what are you- wait what are you-
What are you supposed to do? Hang on, I gotta turn off the TV uh UGH
Wait no hang on wait lady lady no lady no. What if I got a punch her. what if like that's the thing? hang on
Let me get my fists of fury here all right at this point. You're walking into this. Oh god my mouse
Ah AH
Put you right in the tit! *lady screams* Okay, all right then
*Mark laughs*
Lady by the power of my middle finger I compel you to fuck off
*creepy lady screams crazily* okay well
*Mark giggles*
Hang on wait there's got to be something right
*Mark laughs*
I'm not 100 per-
Oh wait what the fuck
I don't- I don't- I don't
I don't know why I'm naked *laughs*
I'm very naked
Hang on if I just don't look at her if I don't look at her she can't get me right if I just look at my
Non-existent dick. I- I'll be fine right. It'll be a hundred percent okay. She doesn't exist. *lady screams*
AH she exists *laughs*
ahhh ahhh
All she's doing it screaming at me I mean wouldn't you scream at someone, too?
If there was a naked man a Ken doll like naked man standing in the middle of your living room watching your TV.
I mean that'd be kind of scary
No, no no no no no no no no no lady. No no no no
*lady screams* okay alright
Hang on wait maybe taunt her. come here. Oh
Gucci Gucci
Come on you come here come a little closer. Give me a smooch come on *laughs*
Come on don't be shy come ove- *lady screams* okay
It seems like certain things that she killed me way faster than the last time
And I'm not sure why
crouch mode all right. Well this just seems
strange *lady screams* *Mark laughs*
Pressing all the buttons middle mouse button oh I can turn
Okay, I can turn
That doesn't oh now
I can move okay
So I needed to go into look mode to be able to get away from her ah so if you go into look mode with
The middle mouse button you can walk. Perfect. Doesn't seem like the most amazing thing. Oh, I probably needed to take that candelabra
I can't exactly see anything well alright. I guess I'm stuck. Crouch mode. There we go. Okay, so I've got a mushroom back off
I've got a mushroom. Okay, nevermind. No. I don't
Hmmm. Well this is precarious. I can't see shit. You're standing over here kill me, kill me *lady screams*
The most
horrible horror game ever made
Hang on, I gotta grab this candelabra, or else I'm not gonna be able to see anything right. okay, shift right lower lower annnnnd
Slot it in slot it in sl- come on slot it in. Okay gonna walk a little closer
closer okay sl- slot it in down grab come on grab she's right behind me!
*lady screams* ah fuck
I'll- I'll try going around the other side and then grabbing *laughs*
Who'd have thought that a- a hand simulator game mode would be- would be something challenging and difficult ah no no, please?
No, it's my only hope no grab it
Ah fuck why couldn't I- it's slow motion
*in slow motion* nooooo
Alright hang on, let me see if I can get it. Oh, okay. Well that almost worked come on come on. It's-
*fake cries* uhhuhuhhuh
I can't grab it!
There's no grabbing happening! alright. Well lady look look. Let me let me level with you lady
I- I'm struggling to do some very basic
I'm trying to cast a spell as you can see by my hands very clearly so you need to back the eff off before I
Slap the shit out of you with some magic bullshit
okay, here we go, there we go
uh Aleca(?) okay, well I'm- all right look lady, look. Can I can I reason with you here, you're not that scary so
Um uh eh uh alright *lady screams* *Mark laughs* here we go
Here we go okay, so no no quickly before it falls before gravity makes it yes, okay, I've got it all right
So I just needed to take the light
Maybe I just need to leave maybe- maybe that's all I didn't really need. Alright. Let me light this. Ooooo
Okay, that's more light apparently can I light fire to this place? Can I light fire to you?
ummm hmm
Okay, well where'd my- what? What? where'd my- where's my candelabra? Axe- that's helpful. Okay. Let me try the axe. where- *laughs*
Where's my- what?!
Candelabra! It's in my pit! Get out of my armpit!
Candelabra! Okay there we go got it okay in my other hand- okay in my other hand
I shall grab an axe
All right hang on. Wait uh shift grab. No. No please no grab okay
I don't have it. Eh, please grab. Please. I'm trying so hard.
Okay. I got it alright alright lady
prepare to meet your imminent demise oh
That doors open nevermind
*laughs* okayyy
I'm out of here baby!
Woah... Oh no
A puzzleee *laughs*
You mean I can't solve it with my
AXE?
Huh well let me try it well, that's not right hang on it comes with a middle finger straight for you alright well
oh g- Why can't I go up? *laughs*
Why can't I- I can't look up! I can't look- It's so heavy alright take some of that
Take some of that
*laughs* okay alright bye see ya
I got- fuckin
What the fuck's going on with my arm
I don't even have it anymore
What the fuck are you doing? What the fuck are you doing!
How the fuck?
Okay, that's wrong alright. Well. Eh I guess that's just my arm now. *laughs* hang on wait nope
alright
Okay *laughs*
Lady you know just kill me. I can't even get to the point where I can try this puzzle, so just fucking kill me
Alright, let's try that again for some fucking reason alright here we go. quickly quickly quickly speed run, baby
Got it alright move like zombie. We're gonna
Set this here. Just like that. Don't get in my way. Please light the other one alright
Let's try this left handy left handy because the other handy is not not worky-worky
Grab. Gently grasp it
Okay, rotateh no ro- rotateh, Ah this is not gonna work
Am I over it? I'm probably over it. Okay here we go
Eh let it go
No, no no, no don't grab your fingers. *sigh*
Oh, well. That w- *lip noise*
Well I'm all kinds of fucked aren't I
looky loo downy-wowny to the groundy
Grab between your legs. Grab the cylinder between your legs. Oh boy. Oh
This ain't gonna work. This this just not gonna work grab it grab- *lip noise*
*breath in* *frusturated ahhhs*
Kill me kill me lady kill me. Where are you kill me? Please just kill me. I- I just want to die
Please kill me. Where are you. I can't see you. Are you in front of me?
Why'd the music stop
*lady screams* OH Fucking what? *laughs*
No no no crap crap crap crap crap *lip noise*
Alright, it's enough. You know what I don't need it. It's fine who needs it
I certainly for one do not. I can't see shit. Alright. I needed it apparently who knew. Alright lady. Just- just kill me *laughs*
rotateh. loonateh. grababeh
Killame killame kalame kalame kalame *lady screams*
no no no grab grab grab. Why are you not grabbing why grabbed grab just- *sigh*
UHHHHHHHH UHHHH *lady screams* UHHHH UHHH UHH
This was my mistakae is that I wasn't crouchakae, okay here we go
Grabobe crap crap. Crap crap. How is that not a grab- crap crap crap? How was that? Hah
How the fuck is not a gra- why! Just grab it haven't you ever grabbed anything cylindrical in your life?
I guess this guy hasn't he doesn't have a dick so
let crouch yeah
It's- aw no
uh. uh
uh uh uh uh uh uh UH UH UHUHUH *turns into screaming*
*confused mumbling*
It's not working
It's not working. It's no-
Gah! There- I'm free oh no
I'm not free I'm the opposite of free hang on wait wait
Wait wait wait wait rotateh rotateh rotateh. Ro- ro- too much rotateh too much rotateh oh
Okay, back back back. Just g- okay. Well that is my back. I am scratching my back
There we are and we're almost through. Let's jiggle that- those bones are not supposed to wiggle like that. I know that for a fact *laughs*
Come on you sack of shit!
Come on come on baby. Okay, well...
Oh. Oh! *lady screams*
*Mark groans*
I got this hang on
Easy easy does it there we go all right. Okay? We are making progresso. Oh whoa *laughs*
So what we got to do
We got to drop this bad boy right there get the fucky outy, so let's do the easiest one first
Oh, that's not gonna be easy. It's on it's side. All right. So I gotta somehow grab it
While also getting it on its side. Let's try not to push it off the edge.
Ooo! Awww
Too far come on
Come on physics. There we go. That's the good stuff. Okay, grab that just gently enough, yeah
Ah
Alright, we're gonna just set it on here for now. Oh boy. It's in that position where it doesn't want to okay
We're just gonna set it right there. No. Oh my god, okay
Let's just set it raise off switch hands cuz righty don't want to play that game. Alright let's just scoot her back
scoot your back scooch scooch
Yeah
baby, yeah, baby
Okay, now. Let's raise this bad boy up on its side. Just like that. Let's grab this bad boy and
Just plunker dunk it right in
That bad boy, okay, let's just let go
Heyyy *happy laughs*
All right, so this one is not whoa be very careful with that okay
Let's switchy swatchy handy wandies
come on let's- okay that- this one doesn't want to cooperate
I thought this would have been one of the easier ones. Okay
Put it up rotateh, rotateh, rotateh back on the correct. Oooo
Oh, man, this one does not want to play nice. Okay
No, it does not want to play
Come on rotateh there. Just like that. Let's drop it on here
Let's just let it go. Okay. It's gone get that out of the way. Oh god. It does not want to stay
Holy shit. Okay. Whatever doesn't matter. She's getting close. Okay
She's definitely got to be getting close, so just rotateh rot- Oh no rotateh let's try
to let er go
Come on. Oh that's new
Okay, all right. Oh fucking hell.
Please just please the other ones went so smoothly. Just let this one okay raise
Extend extend extend. Okay, just got to drop it like this. Just got it let it go. No not on the edge
Fuck me come on
Just fucking come on
Alright, just go and then drop it right on. Okay. Fucking are you seri- are you fucking serious?
God dammit fuck this shit
The fuck is going on okay? Now I'm- Oh where is she? okay still got plenty of time alright
Just fucking I don't know what my arms are doing up there. Oh, no is that out of my range oh no
It's it's oh
No
It might be out of my range oh no no
No, no no no no no no no no no come on
Okay, Oh
Fuckin. Oh my god. Are you?
Okay, if I'm crouch- no. Oh my god.
Oh no, okay, just crouch. Oh my god. Don't go through the fucking table
Okay
Just stay right there. Just stay right- Oh my god. Oh my why why oh I'm through the table, okay?
Well, you know what I'm not gonna complain about it. We're gonna switch. Where's my arm. Where's my other arm? Where's my oh?
Ohhh
Up up up up up up up upupupupupup up
Go up NO, okay, it's fine. I got it here. Okay shift shift
lower
No
It's right there grab. It's right. No. Oh my god. Where's it it's on his end. I don't care. It's on its end
I don't know what the fuck happened get down and move. Okay. Let's move let's move let's move. it's on the correct angle
So let's just grab it oh, no the square the square is underneath that one that that why?
No, it was right there no come on!
Okay
rotateh
Gentleateh gentle nudging
No
Switch handsy, no. No where are you going? No no no no no
Come on! *rock music plays*
*rock music stops* Fucking oh my god
Oh whatever fucking oh my god. Oh come on
This is the most absurd thing the other two went in so easily
I don't get why this one's causing me trouble
It should not be by all accounts this should not be given me any trouble
oh shit
Okay last ditch effort here. Here we go. This is literally it all or nothing here
Can you just behave please? I- Oh my oh...
Ah! Why did you do that? Why did it do that!?
Why did it continually move I wasn't fucking moving the hand and then now it's not moving
It's it's just there's nothing
There's just no fucking God. Just there's nothing
*lady screams*
It was going in it was going in it was going in it was going in it was going in it was going in
It was going in it was going in
It was going in let's go again, let's do it again
Let's do it again here we go. Let's do this
easy-peasy
Okay, cylinder first
Shouldn't be too difficult
Whoa where
What the fuck I accidentally hit the middle mouse button I think
Okay, wait, okay. Let's just get here before it starts destroying itself
Okay, go in that hole and let go. Oh perfect. Okay one down
Let's do the triangle next cuz I don't fucking trust you. Let's just try it
No, it it the the problem with the triangle. I think is that it tips
super easily
So that's its main problem, but with what we learned last time. Hopefully we can alleviate a lot of that
You know we just don't want it to tip is it- ooo
Again with that. We've got all the time in the world
So we're gonna just scooch you
Just barely
No agh, no no no no no no no no no no no no whoa whoa whoa whoa easy there Skippy
Yeah, the triangle definitely hardest one definitely hardest one
I thought it would have been super easy, but it's not just a fluke. It's not just- *lady screams* what the fuck
Need to block her path, I guess
Or close the door. I don't want the fucking oh my god. Oh, just take a shroom
Maybe she just needs to take a shroom break
Yeah
I did think that it was like an exorbitant amount of time that he gave me last time so I guess I am I must
Have done something
To please her let me try knocking the fan in the way nope shroom in the way
This in the way. I don't know man close this door
There we go that's as good as we can get it I think. We'll just do something here. Oh that didn't work
Well alright whatever. Where is this? Why is it behind me? Why is it? Ugh
fucking
god damn it
I'm gonna kill somebody. I'm gonna kill s- That's not what I wanted. Let's just set her- set her down
Let's try to do the triangle first cuz if I can't get the triangle then I'm just boned all around you know what I mean
Okay, get set down
Okay s- OOOOOOOOOH- OH NO-
Coooooock
Cooooock
cooooock
cock cock cock cock cock cock cock cock cock
COOOOCK!
cock coooock!
COCK
cock COACK
CoooOOOOOOoooOOOOOOoooCK
Nope
Fucking not fucking doing it not fucking doing it
Nope, not doing it. Where are you ah? *lady screams*
Nope, nope nope nope nope nope nope nope no no moving on Merry Christmas
Let's have a Merry Christmas. Everybody merry merry fucking Christmas
Merry merry fuck my christmas merry fucking merry crisp. Fuck merry fuckmas merry fucking Christmas
everybody Merry Christmas Merry Chramsmas Merry Christmashin' asshole merry Christm- fuck me Merry Christmas
It's beautiful. It's fucking beautiful. Oh my god decorate the tree
Is that what we're doing here is that why we're here?
Cause we gotta decorated tree. I'm very happy. Let me just grab this
Yep, I have that I'm very happy about that super happy about this predicament
oh, I'm trembling with excitement about Christmas
Trembling with the possibilities of Christmas. Okay?
Don't know where that went. I don't have hands I-I
Don't I don't have hands anymore. I don't- I don't have hands!
Oh, oh, oh hey hand! Hey! There you are where's my other?
Nope, nope! Fucking nope. No! I-I don't have a left hand
Well! Fuck me!
D-I don't have a hand!
I just don't have a hand I don't have a hand guys fucking and where's my right hand going?
Why is my right hand drifting off?
I don't have a hand. I can't even see if I have a hand. I don't even know if I have a hand. do I have hand?
Probably not. There's my there's this hand. Okay. There's this hand and a very conspicuous salute
Yeah, you better put that hand down bitch
*mumbling* Where the fuck is my hand?
*Mark rubs his mouse against his hand*
Nope! Just don't have a hand anymore
That's what I get. Flew too close to the Sun I think
Flew too close to the Sun wish for too much Christmas left me my hands
Just for some fucking reason don't want to stick around. I don't know why this hand is drifting
Now where the fu-
All right, okay, you know what?
*mumbling and whispering* I saw milkmaid what's milkmaid
I don't wanna know what milkmaid
Please tell me- nooooo
Nooooo, Nooo, please! No, no! Anything but this! What are my legs doing?
Oh, no!
Oh no, that's too much leg oh, no
*laughter*
BAP!
*laughing* Bapity bap
Just give that nip a playful bap Oh
BIP Bap bap bap
proper milking technique requires you to
uh Stimulate the udder by slapping it gently back and forth this is true. Do not question this
Alright let's- *cow moos*
*laughs*
*laughs harder*
Well look all right, I'm not happy about this either Bessie
*laughing* Can you just
Wait you have horns
Are you a bull?
Am I milkin' a bull?
Maybe I pulled too hard. Did I-
Is that- is that the problem Bessie? Hang on that's right tease the nipple a bit and then just a little slight nope that didn't work
Uh sumthin' ain't right here hmmm
Uh well... *laughs*
I can't seem to get a good grip on it. You know oh! There we go splashing through my hand
sploosh sploosh all right this feels
Good this feels right this feels like my calling
You know this feels like the true epitome a markimoo here everyone, please uh, please upload-
Goddamnit. Did I pull too hard well fuck
you then Oh No oh poor Bessie?
oh
poor Bessie, I'm sorry, I'm
So sorry Bessie. What can I ever do to make it up to you?
I don't know why we're trying this again. We're trying this again. Bessie, I'm being as gentle as I possibly can here
I don't know what more you want from me. I am I not getting it in the bucket or something Oh
Give you a purple nurple here, we are
You guys need to square up cuz this is this is life here. This is life. That's the good stuff. I'm just a gentle gentle
teasing of the nip
Mmm yep, this is wrong *laughs*
I mean I get it that it's an utter but you know just with the low-poly count
It's not-
That don't seem right all right very gentle
This is gonna get- this is
Demonetised banned - someone's gonna report me to the authorities
The FBI is coming to my house. I am currently being swatted
everyone in the world is- is rushing as fast as they can to stop this from happening like this- this doesn't- this can't exist it's-
But alas here we are *laughs*
Alright, we're almost there Bessie. Hey, you need a break? I'll give you- I'll give your nurple a break. There we go. Nice- nice nurp break.
All right, let's give you a rest before we get to the end here huh? Uh oh. A cock has joined the battle uh
I don't know what to do about that
huh
hoh
Oh *a splashing sound*
Uh!
Did- what? *laughs*
*another splashing sound*
Oh shit I'm spilling- I'm spilling the sweet milk, I guess I gotta do it flat? *laughs*
All right Bessie little more. Sorry. I thought we were done, but apparently we're not. Hang on. Let me just- hold on Bessie hold on Bessie
I gotta- I gotta get more than two fingers on it. There we go. That's- that's proper. That's proper protocol
Bessie please don't kick the bucket. We're so close. I'd hate to lose all this progress *laughs*
*splash sound*
Damn it Bessie, uh hang on let me switch hands here. Uh okay
Let's see if I can get this bucket in proper order because I don't think- I think there's something going wrong here
Hang on- hang on. let me slap that *laughs*
There we go fixed it
Eh fixed it alright- alright
Here we go!
Alright oh Bessie almost to the finish line *laughs*
*splash sound*
Ah shit ah come on Bessie we're so close
Bessie you gotta believe ooOoh *splash as the bucket rolls away*
*laughs*
All right Bessie, well, you know just cuz the bucket is not there doesn't mean that we can't have some fun
*splash sound* *Mark laughs*
*Even more laughter*
Come on I gotta get this guys
One last- one last uh
One last attempt at this
Alright that's obviously not straight, so we need to first let's- oh I had my priorities all wrong
I was- uh I should have been more worried about the state of the bucket.
Alright Bessie. Oh the triple finger hold
You- you never- *laughs* you've never been treated like this Bessie?
Three whole fingers? *laughs*
I know this is the qualiest content
No, I don't think we need to use all the other teets on this cow I think I think this one is primed and ready
You know this is obviously a winner. I don't want the runt of the teat
I want the the prime primo of the teat you know when I go into the restaurant I always I was asked for the
Premo teat so close Bessie, please please we're so close. I mean I feel-
*sad congratulations music plays*
*moo*
Bessie kiss- kick this fucking bucket *laughs*
The fucking bucket *laughing*
*silly scream*
Alright that's enough of that okay. I think that's enough everybody I think that's enough all right well
Hope you enjoyed that that was hand simulator that was-
The best *laughs*
Take care of yourselves take care of each other and take care of your hands most importantly
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always,
I will see you,
in the next video
BUH BYE!!
(Thanks for watching this video!! Hope you like and subscribe on Mark's channel :))